and millions of kenyans are voting in
the country's presidential election the
economic downturn facing the east
african country is a major issue in
what's being called a close race our
africa correspondent yusra al-bagir is
in nairobi for us now and and you sir
just talk us through what is happening
there and and how concerned are they uh
about what the results could be
so we're here at a polling station with
less than an hour and a half to go and
you know the crowds earlier in the
morning just before dawn it was huge
crowds snaking lines things have calmed
down there are fewer lines here but you
can see a steady stream of people coming
in
the voter turnout is yet to be known for
sure they're were concerns around voter
apathy and figures were put out at noon
and only 30 of registers registered
voters had voted by halfway through
election day so we'll know for sure by
the end of the day how many people went
out and voted you know there have been
concerns around violence around the
election because of violence in previous
elections in the
2007 election there was a case of
violence
where at least a thousand people were
killed but we haven't heard of any
protests or riots or use of tear gas
things seem to be relatively calm but
we've been told by experts that actually
the violence isn't an impassioned
spontaneous response it's actually
incited violence by losing caps so the
jury's still out as to whether violence
could be incited could happen after the
result comes out
neutral thanks very much